Docu Series: Why Acting Is Be An Insanely
Dangerous Job
Intro
It’s easy to look at the red carpets, the
awards, the celebrity friendships and million-dollar
paychecks and assume that being an actor is
one of the cushiest jobs around – as long
as you can make it big.
With stunt doubles and special effects teams
on hand to keep everything safe, and the director
and audience asking you to just pretend for
a few weeks, what job could be easier, right?
Well, that’s not the whole story.
Sometimes, the actors who truly make a name
for themselves have to risk more than most
people to get there.
If you value your health, your safety, or
your sanity, then no amount of money is going
to make it worth the risk.
We’re focusing in on the less glamorous
side of the film industry in our latest Docu
Series: Why Acting Is An Insanely Dangerous
Job.
Risking Your Neck
Sure, actors may just have to pretend to be
daring adventurers, soldiers, or fictional
heroes, but they’re specifically being asked
to pretend they’re doing the most daring,
risky things those characters have ever done
in their lives.
And even though there are stunt doubles ready
to handle the major jobs, even small scenes
can put stars in harm’s way.
The world of Star Wars may be fueled by CG,
but when sets are constructed from scratch,
accidents happen – like when a hydraulic
door closed on Harrison Ford while filming
The Force Awakens.
As if it wasn’t bad enough, director J.J.
Abrams learned his lesson coming to Ford’s
rescue - injuring his back trying to raise
the door.
The stories of Hollywood injuries on set are
delivered every day, from Brad Pitt actually
tearing his Achilles heel while playing Achilles,
or Michael J. Fox really selling being hanged
in Back to the Future 3… by actually being
choked.
But sometimes, the injuries can be a bit more
serious.
Charlize Theron has made a name for herself
as a star who can throw some punches, but
when a backflip while filming Aeon (“Eon”)
Flux almost paralyzed her, she promised then
and there that she would never do anything
dangerous enough for a stunt double to be
called in – a decision that worked in her
favor for Mad Max: Fury Road.
Risking Your Life
Sprained ankles and cracked ribs are one thing,
but it seems like acting is a deadlier profession
than most realize – or, at least, it can
be.
It’s hard to believe that even action star
Jason Statham could have kept his cool when
filming Expendables 3, driving a truck with
fault brakes off a pier, crashing into the
water and sinking instantly.
He could have drowned, but at least it would
have been quick, which is more than you can
say for some other A-list actors who have
come close to death.
Statham’s Expendables co-star Sylvester
Stallone learned that fiction and fact can
blur together when filming fight scenes with
Dolph Lundgren for Rocky 4.
Asking the actor not to hold back, Lundgren
delivered a shot straight to Stallone’s
chest.
He knew something was wrong immediately, and
rushed to the hospital to learn his heart
had started to swell from the blow.
It could have proven fatal, but weeks of bed
rest kept the slugger in the fight.
So much for movie magic.
Still, it’s probably George Clooney who
puts the idea that acting is easy to bed.
While other leading men risk their lives in
stunts, like Tom Cruise dangling from the
real Burj Khalifa skyscraper in Mission Impossible,
Clooney had his brush with death after filming
the 2005 drama Syriana.
After seriously injuring his back during an
interrogation scene, weeks of headaches followed
– including a serious panic when spinal
fluid began leaking from his nose.
Clooney has admitted that in the weeks spent
in a hospital bed unable to move, and crippled
by headaches, he seriously considered taking
his own life.
So playing pretend isn’t always fun and
games.
Risking Your Health
The stories of actors dropping weight, or
gaining muscle for a role are well-known by
all movie fans, but it’s still hard to believe
the limits that some actors pushed their bodies
to in preparation for a role.
Robert De Niro set a high bar with Raging
Bull, training to become a completely real
boxer to play Jake LaMotta – before gaining
60 POUNDS to play him in his later years.
That’s a number beaten by one famous method
actor, Jared Leto, who gained a whopping 67
pounds to play John Lennon’s killer in Chapter
27.
He put on the pounds by sticking to a diet
of microwaved ice cream mixed with olive oil,
among other foods, and developed gout in the
process, saying he’ll never again put his
body through the trauma.
It’s not all about weight loss, of course,
but the extra measures taken to deliver the
best performance – sacrificing your health
to do it (and hoping that the audience will
even notice the difference).
Ashton Kutcher learned that copying Apple
founder Steve Jobs’ all-fruit diet was a
bad way to get into character, when he wound
up hospitalized just days before filming was
set to begin.
On the superhero side of things, Hugh Jackman
has turned heads and stunned audiences with
his ripped physique as the X-Man Wolverine,
but even that’s not all workouts and dieting.
To get the shredded, veiny look he wanted,
Jackman had to go days without water to thin
out his skin, suffering through crippling
headaches as a result.
Was it really worth it?
On the far end of the spectrum of actors putting
their health at risk for method acting is,
as always, Oscar winner Daniel Day-Lewis.
Staying in character may be better for the
movie, but when Lewis refused a winter coat
in Gangs of New York, he was struck with pneumonia.
When playing a man suffering from Cerebral
Palsy in My Left Foot, he stayed hunched over
throughout the entire production, even having
crew members feed him so as not to break character.
What he did break, was two ribs, from the
unnatural posture.
It won him an Oscar, though, so it might have
been worth it.
Risking Your Sanity
Putting your body on the line for a role is
one thing, or even refusing to break out of
a character since getting into the mindspace
of the role is seriously taxing.
But what happens when an actor or actress
starts to literally lose themselves in the
role they’re playing?
Ask Anne Hathaway, who went even farther than
the director asked for her descent into poverty
in Les Miserables, cutting off her hair, losing
weight, and delivering an Oscar-winning performance
in the process.
But she admitted that the character was such
a broken, desperate soul, it took her weeks
after filming to break herself out the same
mental troubles, and start to feel like a
normal person.
Yikes.
Taking things even farther, Adrien Brody knew
that his role in The Pianist could be a break
out one – and committed to walking in the
footsteps of a Holocaust survivor the best
way he could.
Leaving behind, his belongings, his home,
and even his girlfriend, and headed to Europe
with a bag and a keyboard.
It’s hard to say if it was his acting chops,
or this method research that won him his Oscar,
but for his sake, we hope it was all totally
necessary.
Shia LaBeouf became more famous than most
young actors for his weird commitment to a
role, and the World War 2-era Fury showcased
the fact that he really is one of a kind.
When the makeup team’s work at applying
a cut to his cheek didn’t seem real enough,
his co-stars say, he simply grabbed a knife,
and cut his cheek open – making sure to
re-open the cut throughout the shoot, and
giving himself a scar for life.
To go with the tooth he had pulled as evidence
of his time in the war (which is never mentioned,
and hardly ever seen on screen).
At that point, the fact that he decided not
to bathe for over a month was probably the
least of his co-stars’ concerns.
And as proof that the most psychotic, unbalanced
villains can’t help but bring something
weird to the lives of those playing them,
both Jared Leto and the late Heath Ledger
seemed to truly lose themselves in the role
of The Joker, Batman’s nemesis.
For Ledger, it meant secluding himself in
a London hotel room for over a month, exploring
the insanity of the character, finding his
voice and laughter.
The reports of his drug use and mental conditions
are almost impossible to decipher by now,
but the fact that such a dark, twisted role
was his last will always be the fact of the
matter.
Maybe it’s lucky, then, that Leto has some
co-workers to let his crazy loose on, in the
form of bullets, live rats, dead pigs, and
apparently even used condoms to his Suicide
Squad castmates.
You can’t say that he isn’t embracing
the role of the Joker wholeheartedly, but
even if he walks away unscathed, it looks
like this is one time where it’s actually
more dangerous to be working with him, not
as him.
Seriously, what are the odds of someone delivering
a dead pig full of bullets to your office?
We rest our case.
So what do you think?
Are these twisted character studies and death-defying
stunts and injuries proof that being an actor
isn’t all it’s cracked up to be?
Or would you be willing to have a brush with
death or two if it meant appearing on the
big screen?
We expect most movie fans would say it’s
worth it, but… some of these actors might
disagree.
Let us know in the comments, and remember
to subscribe to our channel for more videos
like this one.